if you win a game you get a tesla wait
wait what
no way we're gonna play a game of rogue
company that sponsored this video and if
we win
chandler you get a tesla yeah we're
gonna play another game and if we win
you get a tesla and then we're gonna
play a third game and if we win that
game carl you get a tesla and if we lose
all three games
no do you get a tesla i can't take the
pressure carl
search for a game i need you guys to be
dripping and sweat
i'm a sniper i'm going scorch if we win
this game chandler i will buy you a
tesla
guys please and if you're curious what
we're playing we're playing rogue
company the sponsor of this video you
plant and defuse bombs and it's the
first team to win
seven rounds wins so this is the first
of seven rounds guys just just stall for
a little bit if you can
yeah we're flanking blanking no he
flanked me there's three
they were all low guys i'm killing the
one planting i got one down all right
one's on bomb he might be revived
killed one killed one down one down one
last one's on me he's on me he's on me
he's on me
he'll pop up yeah let's go
we just won one round but that's not it
it's the first team to win
seven rounds wins if we win seven rounds
before they do
chandler you get a brand new tesla we
are getting you a tesla chandler
i promise you i'm trying i promise
you're trying to think okay thank you
same strike get ready for a quick rotate
okay the quick rotate is what wins
revealed i've been revealed
oh they split like a bunch of dummies
he's hit for 70. so chandler on a scale
of one to ten how badly do you want this
tesla i rode in your tesla and drove it
without you knowing yeah well let me
kill this guy for you real quick oh he
didn't even buy a gun
baby as i was saying it's super fast and
i love it and it has a screen
also you guys don't have a pretty
backpack like i do look mine has
rainbows on it
get ready for a quick rotate guys ready
for a quick routine and pete
got him 52 i'm coming come and be
they're rotating b oh two two
two rotate oh there's two there's still
two he's rotating flank right
here oh my god i'm insane i'm rushing in
hold on hop and smoke i got two i got
two i got two i got two i got two of
them
two more guys let's go
god we are insane three oh same strat
same strap let's go let's go let's go
chris you got me i got you boy i'm
getting you this tesla let's go
boys support boys men support men
boys don't let other boys go home
without a tesla chandler do you see
anything i've been revealed for some
reason
down one down one down one down one
chandler the one that was on your right
they're in that smoke
on tight on tight on tight i need help
if we win three more rounds chandler
gets a tesla
come on guys please what if what if we
sweep the team
and chandler wins a tesla and then when
it sure has his turn so we just get
destroyed
i really hope that doesn't happen
because i'll feel horrible i'm going
same route oh he's rotating
uh b rotating back side oh oh he threw a
bomb oh two on me two one three on me
i'm so gonna be inside down three down
three i'm so insane i'm so good at video
games it's so unreal
oh my god i can't get over how good i am
at video games oh my god i'm a video
game master oh my god
i don't have to do anything free tesla
carl you better not throw i swear
i have 12 kills i got revealed i got
revealed i got revealed
i don't see anyone eh jimmy jimmy jimmy
run over here rotate quick rotate and
revive i do my bad survivor oh
bombs down a rotate by the way
got one on a bombs down over here up top
one's up top
one's up top chandler he's coming he's
coming down low down low
oh oh they got chandler guys he's pushed
the middle he's middle i'm going to try
and get a trick
guys i'm gonna get a tester i just
quickscoped for your tesla bro
thank you chris we're sweeping them we
have won six rounds in a row if we win
this next one
chandler you are a tesla owner in rogue
company after six rounds you switched
sides so before we were defending
now we're attacking and trying to plant
the bomb play for picks play yup you
have your right side carl
oh i'm downed i'm low low
oh i'm down i'm down he's half health
half health
down two down two down two three i'm
throwing my robot throw your robot
it's going it's going doors down three
down three i downed three of them
oh one of them revived one of them
revived one of them i got you carl
i blinked i flanked someone stopped me
i'm an animal let's go
congrats on your brand new tesla
chris it is your turn
boom we are now in game number two chris
yeah
if we win you get a tesla whoa let's win
i need
i would like that let's go two for two
if we lose will you cry
i don't know i might we'll see what
happens where are we going let's go a
let's go a let's learn a wait so carl do
you think we'll win if we go a uh yes
then i'll go b no jimmy none oh he threw
nade he threw an 8 i'm scared
i didn't know anything dude frick got
one
oh my what he has so little health
okay it's fine it's fine we lost pistol
chris it looks like we're playing some
sweats if you want that tesla
we better step it up boys let's stick
together though we need to stick
together
oh he's one shot one shot where are you
guys at focusing on the people back here
they're rushing us the russian oh my god
these guys are so much better okay i
think b
is better we need to push together that
is the problem we are losing because we
are pushing
it's my tesla jimmy my rules we're
playing less aggressive okay
a few moments later yeah they're all
right here
and i instantly got down will you win
chris tesla
chris tesla you didn't win a tesla but
coral might
one more game i'm gonna try my best for
you okay
and now it is time for the third and
final game carl
this one is for your tesla wait all
right door open door open jump jump jump
okay hey hey hey hey hey oh they're good
they're good someone's flanking us watch
out
oh i'm going to play it i'm going to
play i'm playing playing playing play
okay okay okay it's looking good it's
looking good
get out of my face you nerd oh she's
pushing come come
come i'm coming i'm coming you are a
nerd
champion chris oh she's better she's
coming taylor
get her she's good she's good
hey chandler real quick i got a question
yes what color would you like your tesla
uh
probably white i don't know how about
you spin this round thinking about your
tesla trailer no
i think we go b i think we think about
landing b
i down two i down two i down two the hey
the girl that's really good in our spot
plant who has the bomb plant plant play
and play and play play oh wait i have
the bomb
sight destroyed you can't take my test
look maybe we should try less hard try
less hard jimmy you have one kill
should i get some good speakers in my
car i will say that jimmy's got more
kills officially oh my god the revive i
got the revive stop
oh oh wait where's bomb where's bomb
turn around turn around chris
point the bomb please i didn't know i
had bomb i didn't know i had bomb nobody
told me
please watch me i'm reviving i'm
reviving i'm reviving 30 seconds
oh yeah hey carl guess who just got that
kill
i love you we're 3-0 for carl let's go
i think the most strategic thing i can
do is just to run right at him on a all
right i'm down
also i already won b all right have fun
carl
oh get out of here get out of here chris
chris chris
oh no scope i know scooped him come on
come on let's push him let's push him
right on the corner
he's peeking right now peeking right now
stop me
me and you that was all us carl chandler
just leave the game we'll get the dub
chris if you frag above me by the end of
it you got permanent shotgun what if i
frag above you jimmy you get carsick if
you're not shotgun anyway so
oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot there's three
three on a
oh oh i headshot him right as he
eliminated me
got him they're pushing up they're
pushing up they're on me they're on me
they're standing on top of me
yes let's go since we have such a big
lead let's just use pistols this next
row all
okay i will be very happy i believe in
you guys
oh okay the melee is not a one shot i
thought it was a one shot
oh he's one side oh oh oh oh i'm an
animal she's not she's rising she's
resting she's raising
kill it tell him to die down kill him
while he's still down you're the dummy
oh
guys oh no oh nice price
that might have been our fault for using
pistols and melee defending
defending me and chandler going a okay
okay ming
jimmy go b guns blaze and one of the
cool things about rogue company is it's
literally free to play
i thought you just bought it for us wait
is it actually free it is oh we're
flanking we're playing
got her got him got him got him oh
it's like i was saying it was free to
play and available on the epic game
store this plays like a full-fledged
60 video game you can play this on your
pc your ps4 your xbox
your nintendo switch whatever you want
and not only that but it's 60fps on all
the consoles even your switch that's
insane
on top of that it's even cross-platform
and your progression saves across all
the platforms and there's even a new map
it's the one we were competing on for
chandler's tesla
and there's a new rogue dahlia now let's
go back to giving away teslas guys if we
win this round carl gets a tesla
i'm going try hard i'm going to try hard
i don't care jimmy please
you're going to make me cry oh jimmy you
can throw me a drone
don't worry carl i'm taking care of
business for you oh no
do you realize you could have thrown me
a drone and healed me and we would have
won the game we would win the game right
there and i would have had a car
all right i'll go b don't worry okay me
and jimmy go ahead me and jimmy go away
oh did i say one what i meant to say was
two they planted b rush b
rush b there's one left guys if we
defuse the bomb carl gets a tessa
carl don't die he's defusing he's
defusing oh no oh god
oh god you saw him you saw him hey carl
you're welcome for the tesla
go go go defuse hurry yes yes
how much time do we have left oh whoops
wrong button oh
carl congrats on your brand new tesla
[Music]
they ordered mine but it's on the way
but in the meantime
i didn't get a tesla